a growing number of asian americans are
now buying firearms for the first time
following a surge in hate crimes they're
also joining lobby groups to resist the
democratic party's push for stricter gun
laws
there is a real and imminent threat and
we need to defend ourselves and our
loved ones
we refuse to be silent and we refuse to
be victims
it began uh free covid for me last year
um i'm the father of a mixed asian
family my wife is 100
chinese-american and so is my daughter
and uh we were just walking down the
street as we normally do to go to a
simple park visit uh when a menacing
group of folks uh
showed up in a pickup truck and uh
yelled a bunch of racial slurs at us
and spit at us out the window and that
just really got me thinking you know
what what would have happened if i
hadn't been there uh would they be more
aggressive would they have followed my
wife home and done something even worse
and so that really just kind of planted
the seed in me that
you know you really do have to take
personal protection into your own hands
especially uh
in a vulnerable group like the asian
american community which
historically isn't known for um you know
gun ownership or
things of that nature scott cain has
since
co-founded the asian-american and
pacific island
gun owners group it has thousands of
followers on social media
and encourages responsible firearm
ownership along with resistance to
policies seen as too restrictive
attacks on asian americans have jumped
164 percent in major u.s cities since
the pandemic in comparison to the same
period last year
new york san francisco la they showed
the worst increases with hate crimes
continuing to spike
[Music]
scott cain again says u.s gun culture
has changed and the current
administration needs to take that into
account
i think that uh today's gun ownership is
not um
you know the traditional conservative
bearded dude and tactical gear
um with tattoos and a maga hat um it's
uh minorities
and um people of color you know the
biden administration and some of the
proposals on the table would turn many
of his constituents
into criminals overnight i view our
mission as
educating uh policymakers more or less
to let them
realize that um you know gun ownership
has changed it's uh not the
stereotypical nra member anymore we're
coming from the perspective of
you know liberal biden supporters i
personally have voted democrat in every
election since uh
2004 and uh i think there's just the
real need for this kind of a group in
the uh in the world that has a different
perspective than
people are used to hearing from
you